hey what's up guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to episode 81 of the game
programming so first things first I
stepped up the audio quality hopefully I
am using a completely different audio
setup this is usually the setup I use to
record voice for are either music or
dialogue but I've decided to give it a
shot on recording um stories which is
kind of awkward because there's a lot of
components here to setup in terms of
hardware but anyway hopefully the
quality's worth it um because I think
it's a lot better so anyway getting back
to this there is there will be a bit of
echo because this room isn't soundproof
but it's not padded but hopefully it'll
be alright let me know what you think
though of the UM of the new stuff so
we're going to talk about some pretty
advanced and pixel perfect collision
detection today and the reason we're
going to do that is because we're going
to be simulating particle physics very
very soon we kind of are right now but
we're actually going to step it up a
notch and do bouncing off walls in every
direction obviously the problem with
that is that if our collision detection
isn't absolutely perfect we're going to
get a vast array of errors just errors
and rounding errors in everything so
this really does have to be absolutely
perfect and it's not right now because
what we've been going for right now or
so far in this series is as good
aesthetical collision detection which
means that we want it to look nice we
wanted to look perfectly look perfect on
a word but you know what I mean we
wanted to look perfect we wanted to look
okay okay but in reality the maths isn't
actually perfect behind them so today
we're actually going to pretty much do
an in-depth episode this is the kind of
episode that should belong in an
in-depth series but it is absolutely
necessary that you guys realized this um
and that we changed some of our
collision methods around a bit so let's
take a look at what we've got right now
okay some of this will change her before
the battle so what we've got right now
is when this projectile collides here we
actually grab we actually get a bunch of
particles exploding out of the wall
obviously I said it to explode out of
the right side so if we go to the left
side you can see they don't explode left
they still explode right so they go into
the warm does it look nice okay
obviously I'm aware of that that was
just to demonstrate what it would kind
of look like once we added some kind of
bouncing here now they aren't bouncing
right now okay all we're doing is we're
setting we're basically saying that if
for some reason this XA variable which
is the the X direction of where we want
to animate our next frame true if that
if that direction is a negative let's
make it positive that's what we're
saying right now so in other words they
cannot possibly go left
these particles because we're overriding
that now that's a very that's pretty bad
way of doing that and the reason it's
bad um first and foremost is because
it's it's situation right there's only
this something works in one situation
and we could do a bunch of web settings
being like a cable if we hit the wall
from the right side but the thing is if
we if we do that we're going to get a
seriously a lot of problems because look
at these walls there is no way that we
can handle all of these precise corners
here that's going to be an I'm at a
handle which is why we actually need to
implement some kind of physics here so
the first problem that we have is
probably stems in our wizard projectile
class which is actually open already now
I'm not going to touch the players
collision okay that's irrelevant
absolutely relevant right now
players collision to walls is only there
for a statical reasons okay there is
absolutely no simulation that needs to
go on wanna play collapse of the wall
the only reason that this wall collision
actually exists is because we want to
stop players from getting out of the
level or going you know getting out of
corridors whatever we just want to stop
him we're not simulating anything and
because we're not simulating anything
there's no need to improve that
collision okay that's I'm putting a
blunt okay there's actually no need to
improve that collision it works fine as
it is right now feel free to improve it
for yourself if you want but this is
usually here for aesthetic arrests now
sorry I just hit the hit the microphone
cable now for our particle collision
though or let's just start with our
projectile collision that needs to be
absolutely perfect now why does it need
to be perfect okay why the reason is we
add a particle spawner at that location
at the location of where we actually
collide now the problem obviously is
that if we collide and we you know are
already inside the wall just a fraction
we're going to get an error because when
we're actually going to get an error but
what's going to happen is all those
particles are going to spawn already
inside the wall and they're not going to
be able to get out of the wall because
they're already in there and really we
just want to fix that up a bit so I'm
going to control click on this tile
collision if you're not using Eclipse
then I don't know how you do that but
I'm just going to go to the level class
and in the level class we we do have a
method that we made call tile collision
now all this is quite situational with
this times 2-12 stuff we want to kind of
make this Universal a universal method
that we can use to make any entity
collide with a tile or rather check for
a collision in a tile and the way that
we're going to do that is we're going to
change around a lot of these parameters
now let's just take a look at what we
need first okay what do we need to
collide an entity with a tile we need
preferably it's some well essentially
what we need right is its X&Y a location
where it's going and the size of it
which is what we seem to be declaring
here that's roughly what we need okay
this x and y i then ever use separately
if you notice here we only ever use them
in use them together we just add them
together so in other words what that
tells me right now is that that can be
done outside of this so what we really
need is when your next coordinate we had
a y-coordinate and we need a size
there's actually one more thing we need
then I'm not going to cover right now
but that's what we need that's all we
need okay so these two if you just don't
know that already these two can both be
accessed through out through through an
entity okay so if we just open our
entity class and I'm literally talking
about our entity class you can see we've
got an S is you're here for x and y now
we've got a double here for x and y and
that's not that doesn't mean matter yeah
we seem to be overriding and we do have
doubles here but that's okay that's fine
that'll still work
in fact we probably don't exactly need
to keep them as doubles um when they get
fed in but because of the fact that
sometimes we do have doubles I'm not
going to probably use an entity I am
just going to make a user you feed in
numbers so what I'm going to do is I'm
still going to make sure this is an
integer okay
but I'm only going to make X and why I'm
not going to make X nya so we've got X Y
and a size again that is a very very
universal method okay that can be used
for anything now let's clean this code
up a bit we don't need this anymore
or weird is X and for here all we need
is why okay pretty simple I think we've
got an extra bracket somewhere because
it's complaining maybe here yeah great
okay so at the moment looking a lot
cleaner let's go back to wizard
projectile and fix this little arrow
here I'm going to change X to be n/a to
be X plus NX and I'm going to change Y
to be at y plus NY which is of course
our translation vector and I need to
cast them as an integer so I'm going to
cost them as an integer after they've
been added together that's probably
going to be more precise if not we can
change at any time of course so I want
to add them together then calls them to
an integer and that will give me pretty
much the pixel to which they want to
advance to these projectiles of ours now
back in the level this thing is is quite
random here and as in these numbers okay
they're not actually bet they're just
again a cycle we're kind of playing
around with those numbers until we get
something that looks okay
now we're gonna do it mathematically now
I'm not going to draw you a diagram
because we're going to be here a half an
hour if I do because this is quite
complex if you want to see this again
I'm raising my voice you guys can hear
me or you look already dozing off if you
want to see me explain this properly and
actually draw your diagrams who you
absolutely understand this let me know
I'll make a separate video that's not
part of this series that will cover this
four corner collision detection in like
about 30 minutes so that you get
everything about it but all you need to
know right now
is that these are the four corners of a
tile a tireless square okay
anything that's rectangle this for
conical intersection works for in fact
it's probably the preferred method
especially if there's no serious physics
involved and by serious physics I mean
like uh you know squares plotting with
circles or whatever and actually working
out vectors did to do with that but what
we need to do right now is we we need to
calculate these four corners now the way
that we do this roughly is when if we
take C mod two since C is less than four
that's how many times we do we do it
we actually loop through the followed
four times right so for each time we
loop C zero zero one two or three right
because if it's less than four we get
out of the loop so if it's greater than
four we get out of the loop if it's
greater than or equal to four
we get out of the loop because if it's
less than four we continue to loop so in
other words we get the values of C being
zero one two and three
now if the values of C are either zero
or two this will equal to zero okay
because we're modding it by two
now if C is 1 1 mod 2 is actually equal
to 1 and so is 3 more 2 so what happens
is if this is equal to 0 which is in the
case when C is 0 and 2
I'm chronic complainers briefly by the
way then we get 0 here and obviously is
your x size is 0 okay and because of
that we get 0 for here and and for here
so all we're really doing is subtracting
12 from X now for the other ones this is
equal to 1 1 mod sorry this is equal to
1 so we just get one time side so what
we're doing effectively by doing this is
we're just having a way to either use
this size or not so we're making
ourselves a way to either add this size
to the X or not and by doing this we're
enabling us to check the other corner
the corner is further away from the
origin and that's roughly how it works
okay so in order to fix this we first of
all need to change this to a subtraction
and all we need here is just the size
let's get rid of this okay that's the
most basic form of this all we're doing
is if we're we're currently in the for
loop at the appropriate core
we're just going to subtract the size of
this rectangle or in other words well
for this the width for this too high but
because it's a tile collision and tiles
are square we don't need it separate
within hide variables since they are
equal to each other so and why of course
does the same thing before why now this
is pretty basic I am going to change
this just a quick optimization here I'm
going to change this divided by 16 to
right shift by 4 that's the same thing
does exactly the same thing because 2 to
the power 4 is equal to 16 ok this is a
quick optimization most compilers
probably do it for you but it's probably
I actually find this more readable to be
honest but anyway the point is that
we've got this nice equation here now
this is going to be pixel perfect okay
as long as the size is the size of the
object we're checking against now this
is where the interesting stuff comes in
if I open our folder here let me just
find it if I have now game programming
and we go to rain and here we are in
resources we have textures of course and
we have our sheets and we have
projectiles
let's open up wizard 2 project dot PNG
and we'll open it with paint on map so
if we open this what we see here is that
this is drawn in the center ok obviously
we'd be checking in the top-left corner
that's obviously the origin this is in
the center though that's a bit of a
problem it's not really but it is a bit
of a problem because collision won't
occur here collision will occur here now
we need to offset it because of that so
we need to offset it 5 pixels to the
right and 4 pixels downwards so we just
need to remember that so what we need
here because of that is an X offset and
a Y offset and what we're going to do is
we're going to subtract this x offset
here and we're going to subtract the Y
offset in the Y okay and this is pretty
much going to give us a really really
precise collision detection method if we
go back to where the projectile we'll
have to add these values now the size is
7
I'm kind of regretting that a close
paint on that but if I open it right now
and we'll just open them
the reason stuff that we're doing which
is a wizard yep if we check put it if we
take a look at that our sizes as you can
see seven so width is 7 pixels and our
height is 7 pixels that's why I'm using
size 7 okay but what we also need to add
right now is the offset so 5 & 4 okay
very very simple and let's take a look
at what that looks like right now so you
can see that it's made pretty much no
difference here but what you should be
able to see is um I think we may have
offset it the wrong way though so let's
make sure that we do keep the offset
correct yeah there we go okay so it
looks like it has to be plus but yeah so
what we're doing here is we're keeping
the collision are ridiculously precise
here you can see that it's not making
much of a difference because again we'd
match it aesthetically a bit right now
it's actually hitting the tile and
that's what's kind of causing it to stop
so with that in mind that is that is the
collision method that we're going to use
ok so again all you need to remember is
you want to subtract see mod 2 times the
size of your collision that you want to
detect and then you want to add an
offset to it if if required okay and
that's for the X finally you go for so
you want to divide it by the size of
your tire so that you get it in top
precision and you can actually get the
irrelevant tile here injected solid but
the same thing happens for Y except with
/ - of course
and using the Y variable instead of X
but that is going to give us the basis
of the collision that we're actually
going to use for our particles and in
fact what we're going to do we're
actually going to write our own
collision method here we're not going to
UM actually use this one because we need
more parameters than this we actually
need specific parameters such as the
direction since we do want to create
physics but that is going to be the
basis for precise collision detection
for our game again so again if you want
me to demonstrate this may be without a
tile our thing may be right a quick game
and just demonstrate this contact of
this concept with two rectangles and
draw diagrams all that stuff for an
in-depth episode let me know I'll gladly
make that and because this is something
that collision detection is something
that people do not understand very well
and it's something that you really
should understand very well okay so that
is wrapping up episode 81 of game
programming one thing I want to mention
guys is that um I am quite I'm actually
quite busy right now in my life
and because of that making these game
programming episodes something I really
want to do but it's something I find
hard to deal with times so I'm going to
cut you guys a deal okay for every 100
likes that a video gets and by video I
mean game programming video so this one
for example for every 100 likes that
this video gets I'm going to release an
extra video game programming so in other
words if it's a Saturday and I wasn't
planning to release an episode today I
will release one today okay
that's how it's going to work so every
hundred likes if there are 200 likes in
this video I'm on all these two episodes
300 likes three episodes thousand likes
ten episodes
okay not even kidding so that's going to
be the deal that I'm cutting with you
guys because likes first of all motivate
me to do this honestly if I see people
liking my content I'm like dude I want
to make more and second of all because
likes actually help my channel grow
which is something that is obviously a
good thing so um that is episode 81 of
game programming if you did hit a like
button and I will make many more
episodes to come and let me know if you
want that in depth the in depth series
or at least for this episode for
collision but other than that guys
thanks for watching seriously and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
you